[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits the podcast
where two lifelong friends talk about
life for a long time i'm link and i'm
rhett this week at the round table of
dim lighting we are hearing your voice
is
because you called and you answered the
question we want to hear your bad
neighbor slash roommate horror stories
give us a call and share your story at
1-888
yeah
you know i've i've had some neighbors i
have neighbors in the past
on this show you have discussed
some you got into some viciousness with
your neighbors you got into the deep end
of yes strife uh
we will not recount that in detail uh
but yes when i moved into my current
home
my neighbor that was really my only
neighbor that we like you know had
contact with like physical contacts like
we shared a fence with them
your your land the way that my house is
situated they're really the only
neighbor that you can really like have a
fence with and stuff
but anyway yeah we had a tree dispute
bush dispute
there was uh there was a bunch of
arguing that went back and forth oh
because you basically planted a palm
tree on their land but right next to
your driveway
yeah after we talked about cutting down
a
bush that was theirs
anyway we had coffee and we straightened
it out and now we give each other
christmas gifts
but what r so what was the the what is
the long term takeaway it's been so long
since that like well what is this is it
that what i think i'm a bottle of wine
well what i tell people on a
on the rig
when they begin telling me their
neighbor stories is i say
you gotta nip that
neighbor situation in the bud yep
because you cannot abide
in this way where you've got some just
ongoing dispute it's not it's not life
is too short to be in an ongoing dispute
with your neighbor even if what they are
saying and doing in my case i thought
that is unreasonable i was like i don't
care how unreasonable this is i don't
care who's right and who's wrong in my
mind you were wrong
you love to throw me under the bus i was
not wrong but i didn't go back and buy a
long shot but that's my that was my
takeaway uh it was pretty simple but the
the point being that it doesn't matter
who's right or who's wrong it really
doesn't matter i hear that
reconciliation is the most important
thing that's the right that you're
looking for when you're in a neighbor
situation now somebody might be
unwilling to compromise but as i told
you in the previous story which has been
years now
when i
sat down at a coffee shop with my
neighbor
he immediately began to weep
that's right because
he knew that he was in the wrong
okay yeah i've forgotten that part yeah
so thanks a lot when the person's crying
that's uh wow you you broke them you
didn't cry
uh no i didn't ha i had nothing to cry
about
yeah well the you talk about nipping in
the bud
but
to me just to skip to like the final
analysis here if you have any
opportunity to like build
some positive rapport with a neighbor do
it that's why when people move in next
to you
you give them cookies you welcome to the
neighborhood you give them a little
welcome package or something you
introduce yourself
then you don't have to worry about when
are we going to meet
what circumstances are we going to mean
under and is it going to be when i have
to confront them about something like
these voicemails we got yeah or like
you're oh i'm doing some work on my
house and they're a nosy neighbor and
they're going to come over to see if
i've got the i pulled the right permits
and stuff you know that happens all the
time in california yeah it happened it
happened with us with we never knew
which neighbor it was yeah you guys
ended up having a like situation spend
thousands of dollars doing stuff we
didn't plan on doing but you have uh
you have a good situation in your
neighborhood i do my cul-de-sac
right there all around the end we all
know each other and
party together a couple of times a year
and we've got sometimes a little too
hard chris heard yep christy's on a text
thread with
some of those people i'm not on that
text thread that's where i draw the line
you can get hammered in a cul-de-sac
though oh man yeah i'm saying because
it's only one way out yeah right it's
like it's really hard to get hurt like
it's really hard to get run over in a
cul-de-sac yeah that's right you know
because it's just like it's just well
it's just the end of the road
so you don't get hammered by a car
i'm just saying you can get him again a
cul-de-sac a place where a road
terminates surrounded by homes
it just feels like a place that you can
just lose yourself
you know oh you let it all hang out we
did man yeah it's like you can't do that
on a thoroughfare and you know what i'm
saying nope you got to do that in a
place where listen you saw this and if
you're going to tell somebody about it
we're not going to let you leave and we
can all keep you here because it's just
one way out yep it's about barricading
if you live on a highway you can't get
away with anything
um and then it the the cul-de-sac then
it extends
it curves around and then extends to the
main road so like one of the things we
discussed at our last party was how
this was not me talking either it seems
like something i would say in a group to
make see how everybody reacted
but one of my neighbors said yeah we're
in the balls
of
the street
and then you kind of drive down the
shaft of the street to get out to the uh
to the main thoroughfare
those are pretty little balls if you go
those proportions well it's basic it's
it's just the cul-de-sac
is a nut sack i understand the analogy
i'm just saying that if i were to take
an overhead view of your street knowing
about how long it is the balls are
proportionately those are small it's
very cold in that cul-de-sac if you know
what i'm saying cold it's very cold
that's why it's called that a cold sack
oh
it's very shriveled figured it out yeah
i got a good you live at this
small end of the sack with my neighbors
there was this whole thing about my
window from my shower giving me a
vantage point to my neighbors which then
i talked to them about it and it's like
i want to make a video about this they
were super cool about it you know
they've since put up a fence that then
kind of makes it a little more difficult
for me to see them they're super cool
since then they have put up a barricade
yeah on the other side we got new
neighbors and
they're below me and there's that wall
this is the guy who threw you uh threw
you something off his grill no no no
that's the guy that's my that's my
backside neighbor
i'm talking about my other side neighbor
my backside neighbor i saw him
uh on a walk with the dogs a week ago
and i was like hey i'm link i'm i'm your
neighbor up there and he was like oh
yeah and he made the motion
he's like i threw it what are you
throwing the meat what did he throw what
kind of meat um
like a
hero meat on a shish kebab he took it
off the morsel a morsel he took like a
hamster i threw the morsel he yeah so he
made the he made the throat
he was like oh yeah he was like next
time come on down
uh he's oh he was baiting you and i
yeah and i remember his name now that's
the other thing write down your
neighbors names
like i put in my phone
person's name and then i put neighbor so
then when i can't remember my neighbor's
name i just searched my address book for
neighbor yeah and it's like all my
neighbors from all the years come up you
got to make a good
you got to start on a positive foot
because inevitably there will be
conflict as we see and with my new side
neighbor there's that
cinder block wall
and walls are trouble who owns them eye
on the wall uh but how do you really
know because i do and then i look over
there they probably think the same thing
and they've done
all types of landscaping once they moved
in including
planting trees that
line the wall on their side so they
don't have to look at the back side of
my wall they can look at the trees
there's a cinder block christie wasn't
happy with what they planned i wish they
would have asked me what type of thing
to plant i could have helped them come
up with something better and i'm like
well the only thing i'm worried about is
the fact that these trees that they
planted
are going to keep going up and up and up
and when i sit at my dining room table
and i look out that side window i can
see a little bit of the mountains
and i don't want to see a point blank
range tree is it like those very typical
like california like they're going to
get really tall and they look like they
might be evergreen bushes that just keep
going straight up it's a it's small it's
a smaller um
i would call it it's a tree but it kind
of has a
bush like bush-like quality
but i can i could already tell when they
first planted it i was like there's a
few that are higher and like i'm sitting
there
looking out my window
and and my my
vantage point of the mountain is being
threatened from a seated height
by these freshly planted tree things
so i need somebody to come over and like
accidentally
be like wielding
a
what is it a scythe a scythe yeah and
like oh the tall guy came over the sith
like talk lord i could come over here
this is it this is the plan halloween
night i make a great grim reaper i bring
my sith
or scythe
scythe
you know what i'm talking about and uh
i'm just having a grand old time it's a
cul-de-sac so i get a little hammered
and i start swinging that thing around
and i just cut the tops of their bushes
off and i do it every halloween
oh it's a way to keep it controlled i
appreciate the offer but i've already
taken care of it oh
snap
yeah it was under the cover of darkness
um because it's
on my
like my side there's the wall which is
like
four and a half feet tall maybe even
five feet tall and then there's like
another foot of tree that's now on top
of that and it's right there at my eye
level my hand level when i'm like
if i say if i had clippers in my hand
like some sort of landscaping shears
let's just say i did let's just say it
was dark oh gosh and let's just say from
my side it's just it's just right there
conveniently snip snip snip snip snip
from their side the top of those trees
is probably
uh seven or eight feet oh really because
their how their plot is lower than mine
so
i tried to to snip off every single one
in a very natural uneven natural pattern
this is just nature so it doesn't just
look like i just
went across the top like epic rap battle
of manliness opening scene
so
i gotta but i i did that like six weeks
ago i already have to do it again under
the cover of darkness you want to come
over
we could we could get in there you are
trimming your neighbor's bushes
at night just to keep them at the right
level i mean
they can't get any taller well you might
be in some way you might be creating
bonsai
you know what i'm saying like if you if
you keep a tree from growing
i thought you were gonna other things
start happening no that's not gonna
happen well i i thought you were gonna
say
maybe you're creating maybe you're doing
your neighbor a favor which is how i am
looking at it i can conveniently trim
their tree
without them even having to pace do you
hold do you grasp the bush and trim it
so you keep the the trimmings on your
side hell yeah
who do you think i am so all the
evidence is oh yeah yeah yeah and i have
a and if you know what if they
happen to get curious and notice and
like maybe i see him in passing and
they're asking about like
these trees are supposed to be 16 feet
tall now
if they ask me about it i'm gonna say i
don't know
that would be a lie but i will say that
i'm going to lie
and i'm going to say
i don't know but i haven't noticed maybe
i'm maybe my
landscapers are are trimming that just
as a courtesy to you oh you could say i
i'm i'm asleep i'm a sleep trimmer
yeah so it's like i don't remember doing
it but i might i only trim bushes
while sleepwalking
it's including my own i'm not what i'm
doing isn't right and i'm not proud of
it i don't know but but i'm not it is
against the law probably technically i'm
not i don't think you can touch your
neighbor's bush without consent prepared
to do
anything else like i'm not prepared to
do the right thing which i don't even
want to know what that is
but unless you want to tell me i mean
what's the right thing to do here
talk to my neighbor
mr f
i mean
we do know each other we're on a first
name basis we met at a cul-de-sac party
right when they moved in
and but they really they really keep to
themselves okay have you looked at the
bushes from their perspective
no you want me to sneak into their
backyard and look back up so it's the
backyard it's the backyard
okay okay okay
uh i don't think they would mind but i
don't want to take the risk to ask okay
this is what i would do if i were you i
would get a selfie stick
okay
approximately
10 feet long
uh you got to do this when they're at
daytime when they're not there
and you
uh put your your phone on wide angle and
you stick it into their backyard and get
a look at what their perspective of
their bushes would be if you're not
gonna be helpful oh i'm not gonna you're
wasting my time i'm not kidding that's
step one so you actually can appreciate
like oh yeah totally fine if you get
down there and you're like oh no this is
i'm ruining this from their perspective
which i don't think is the case i just
think you gotta confirm because then i
do think you go to them
and uh the fact that you the fact that
you've been trimming already
uh i'm just saying if you want to do the
right thing i'm not saying this is what
you should do i'm saying if you want to
do the right thing i think the thing
that i would do is i would keep trimming
the bushes at night
and just it would probably never become
a thing
yeah
which is probably what you're going to
do but if you want to do the right thing
i'm a night bush boy i would i would go
and i would say hey um
i'm a i wanted to talk about your bushes
uh
you know
i
i feel like if we just let them keep
growing it's really gonna obstruct our
view but i my assumption is that you
guys don't really care
that they that they need to get taller
than you know the seven or eight feet
that they are and kind of covering you
know i'm sure it's just kind of
beautifying your experience in the back
and you're not looking at a cinder block
wall
um you know i didn't want to come over
without asking so i did stick a selfie
stick over the fence and i i know what
it looks like for your perspective in my
my mind it looks great i i here's the
video i think the chant says the only
risk is that they want it to grow taller
because from their vantage point they
want to block something that is
currently being seen you won't know what
that is unless you do the selfie stick
method you you need a
the key to winning an argument is
knowing everything that the opponent is
thinking
everything about their perspective
you basically need to steal man their
argument not straw man i know what i'm
gonna do bush man i know what i'm gonna
do i'm gonna pick a time when they're
not there
i'm going to
throw
a ball
into their pool
oh in the backyard i'm going to go i'm
going to knock on the door
when nobody comes to the door i'm going
to go into the backyard
of their house and i'm going to retrieve
my ball okay and while i do i will have
the perfect vantage point even if they
have cameras
i was just getting my ball i was just
getting my ball and looking at you yeah
we saw you on camera aiming for her
bull because the bushes are too short
and then we didn't block or didn't block
it they're going to get you on camera
that's that's the weakness in this one
and i'm going to get lando to do it
uh yes i'm going to bring a child into
this yeah our our child is strange he
just he loves to throw balls
you want out of boundaries no you're too
tall and then i'm going to look and i'll
know this is the grim reaper if there's
something to block and then if there's
nothing to block vertically then i'm
just going to keep night night trimming
what about your pool equipment
do you think that they're blocking your
pool equipment
uh yeah but that's not an issue it's a
lot below them it's lower
but yeah
so i'm just gonna do them what i think
is a favor and if i get back into a
corner and i have to admit to it
i'm just going to you know i'm going to
work i'm going to work my link charm you
know i've never been punched in the face
well
and i've deserved it a lot one small
thing way i kind of relate to this let
me know hashtag your biscuits by the way
as i uh you know we've kind of like um
or 188 earpod one yes we know please let
me know uh
i've kind of landscaped a little area
there uh
next to my home yes and i have uh i've
entered i've crossed the boundary it's
not your land i'm 10 feet into the next
yard but it's an empty lot and we're
just like
nobody lives there
that's fine but you did the right thing
but one of the things and there's also
like after a while it becomes my land i
don't know how many years it is in
california
but after a while i get it just because
i've staked my claim imminent domain
that's not but we have a little bench
that we've set up there to kind of like
i'll go out there and have you have you
sat on my bench i haven't yeah we have a
little bench over there now that you can
watch the sunset you can look over the
whole neighborhood it's wonderful
i have a glass of wine i haven't done
that yet but i've definitely thought
about it
but there keep a box of wine underneath
the bench there's one tree
oh yeah about two
like two roads away that's a pretty
large tree it's pretty tall you know
what say no more yes i will help you
chop down this tree no this is my plan
so
i think that it may be maxed out i have
no morality when it comes to landscaping
and other people's trees don't have
souls
i think that
this tree um
is done might be done growing but i'm
keeping a really close eye on it and
it's in and if it isn't done growing it
could obstruct my view of the sunset
here's my plan
because i'm sure these people are proud
of this tree
i'm gonna get into archery okay
and i'm going to
poison the tip of a arrow
with some sort of like like a like a
beetle colony oh no yeah i'm going to
put like a egg sac of a beet of a tree
killing beetle and i'm going to aim at
the trunk from the dist in the cover of
night i'll be how many damage you're
going to do when you miss no no i'm um
first of all
you're going to be beetle investigation
i'm going to train for months to this is
i get one shot at this
and i'm going to have
at the cover of night i will be dressed
as the grim reaper and i will have on
night vision goggles and i'll be sitting
on my bench
and i will aim at the trunk of that tree
it'll be probably a crossbow because you
can aim a little bit better the crossbow
with the beetle colony
on the tip
goes right into they'll never know what
hit the tree because it'll also be a a
disintegrating a disintegrating arrow
right here don't forget that an arrow
that biodegrades
quickly very quickly no on impact it's a
wooden arrow that the beetles eat
once they're it's the first thing the
larvae eat when they come to life just
make that arrow look like a tree limb
even better idea right
it'll be so high up it's gonna be like
60 feet in the air not a good idea we
don't know what happened to that tree
but when it finally fell what there was
an arrow in what's the problem part of
the tree though the top well here's what
i think you should it's not a problem
yet but it might be one day yeah
what i think you should do is
you should approach those people and say
i would like
you explain your situation and you say i
would like to pay
for your trees to be trimmed that's
something that we all have to do i would
like to cover the cost of that whenever
you do it next time and all i'm asking
is that they also top off the tree which
is something that they do it helps them
keep the trees
uh healthy a lot of trees in our area if
you'll notice especially like those
pines they got bad tops they top them
off so they have a blunt top because
when you're when you're there when it's
in your yard you never
that has no impact on you right you
can't see that but i think it helps the
health of the tree i'm no arborist
but it really helps your view and
there's places like that that i've
thought of i thought about going all the
way through like miles from my house and
like tracking down the owners of these
trees and just like just throwing money
at them to top so i can top their trees
well just cut the tops right off we did
we we did cut down
uh
a few trees in that in that lot that we
don't own
uh not because of the view that's called
brush clearance that's a favor
it was because we had been told by
somebody who knew what they were talking
about it wasn't like an arborist but he
was like someone who had a good friend
who was one okay uh
and he was like that those trees are
friend of the trees those trees are
about to fall into the neighbor's yard
and also it's a fire hazard and so we
were like yeah and we paid for it out of
our pocket and we tried to contact the
owner of the lot and he didn't get back
to us and so we just cut him down
um
all right yeah that's another dilemma
let us let us know i like the fact that
we have this voicemail and of course now
we're going to listen to your voicemails
after we talk about our new freaking
party game yeah we're still good now you
know we're we're uh we're really into
games especially me i have a game night
that i actually haven't reinstituted it
yet but but now's the time pre-painted
i motorcade getting people together and
i love games you know
cards against humanity kind of started
this whole craze of the party game
that's not a complicated board game with
rules and everybody's sitting around a
table it's not a tabletop game it's a
party game that's based on cards and
tokens
and it's also just based on
taking a horrible scenario which is
actually just ridiculously hilarious but
a negative scenario and putting a
positive spin on it and then picking the
best positive spin there are some cards
and it's not completely just a creative
exercise you get to like fill in the
blank it's incredibly fun we've played
it a couple of times there's two stages
to each round which makes it more fun
and i think original you can play in
teams you can play as an individual you
take a scenario that has a blank and
then everybody submits one of the cards
that they have
acquired randomly and then the judge in
each round
decides to fill in the blank and make
like this crazy negative situation right
and then
everybody for the second phase of this
round
then has to put a positive spin on this
crazy scenario once the blank has been
filled in and the judge picks the person
that uh picks the one they like the best
it could be like it's fine you the card
could be you just found out that in the
middle of the night your neighbor is
blank and you might get a card that says
shooting a beetle-infested arrow at your
biggest tree
you're like we're still good because i
hated that tree because
i love beetles
my favorite band you see the beatles are
my favorite band that would be a funny
that would yeah that's the example of
one that might be chosen so we're still
good
just
holding the box i wish i had it right
now
it's
satisfying to say there's a there's a
physical
game that we have developed that you can
on
and increase your mythicality and if you
get drunk in a cul-de-sac on a regular
basis it'd be real fun in a cul-de-sac
while hammered
let's listen to a voicemail yes
hi there guys i have a very interesting
not roommate but a neighbor story so i
live in an apartment
college apartment i try to make this
pretty quick
heard a loud noise outside looked
outside someone smashed one of our
lights the girl across from me was
confused we both confused to go back
inside my roommates then come home and
they're like hey someone's peeing in the
damn hallway
so they're taking a piss in the hallway
i finally i'm like okay this is enough i
come out there and i'm like hey man what
are you doing
immediately
whips around at me lisa pulls his pants
up beforehand good throws his shirt off
as quick as you can and pretty dang
quickly is in my face ready to fight me
definitely much taller than me much more
built on me and i'm like oh man i didn't
want to fight you i just don't want you
taking a pee in the hallway that i live
in
so until it happens a bunch of people
come out and dissolve the issue and you
know it ended up working out in the end
i didn't have to fight jade buckley but
pretty dang interesting story and yeah
they were very interesting to live with
for the rest of that time
thanks guys
yeah cause after that
just that
big guy with his shirt on or off you
never know what you're gonna get
is is he's still around obviously he was
under the influence of something if
you're gonna pee in a hallway it can't
be your own it can't be i mean still
just to get that out of the way there
are there are circumstances in which
pissing in a hallway
is probably permitted
you know what i'm saying
like uh
i don't know i'm if i'm i'm just saying
let's just say yeah tell me what [ __ ]
i'm waiting
okay might be
that uh
you're
you're being held up
you know like maybe you're being held up
at gunpoint okay you're being held
hostage and so in a hallway and you
never have to pee well after a while you
never know how no i'm saying that like a
lot of people if you point a gun at them
they they pee you know what i'm saying
i've never had that happen to me what
about i don't know what i would do being
stuck in an elevator you're gonna you're
gonna pee in the corner even though you
know you got to stay there and if you
can get your tallywhacker out the uh
the split of the elevator you it'd be
better to pee into the hall this is a
perfect situation then it starts going
and that thing clamps down
no you get everyone else in the elevator
because assuming you're not alone to
hold it open just big enough for your
tally wacker to go out into the hall and
pee because that's what they want they
don't want you peeing inside the
elevator that we're all stuck in no pee
out
into the hallway
that would be acceptable
who first who transferred the
terminology of tallywhacker to you
because that
i got it from you when we were when we
were like kids that's what uh that's
what my parents called it when they were
growing up
tally whacker
yeah tally whacker
they didn't i'm saying so italian when
they were
they didn't call they didn't call it a
tally whacker for me we called it
ding-dong
okay yeah it was always very confusing
because i always thought somebody was at
the door
um but
tally whacker is what they called it in
south georgia way back in the day and
you know what i called it from when i
like
stayed at like preschool pre-preschool
as early as i can remember
i i yeah i'm gonna when you say it i'm
gonna remember it apito
yeah
that okay why somebody referred to it as
that and it kind of makes sense
you know
you're you're a preschooler
you don't have a third leg you just have
a 11th toe
that you pee out of get your p house but
it sounds so much like something else
pito
i mean it's so close
i mean p double e t o e i mean it's like
if you know you know but if you don't
yeah you might think it's pedo i
understand that now but i didn't then
thank god i didn't know what that was
but this back to the situation and this
is this is ridiculous first of all when
you approach somebody doing this
that that's a delicate situation because
he's always like hey buddy like yeah
yeah it's like you got to say you got to
say something approach with a bucket and
just start catching it because i think
there's
some people like what what the hell dude
he took his shirt off immediately i mean
that is that is what you're afraid is
going to happen he was an angry drunk
and why is he taking it
he don't want to get blood on his shirt
that's a sloppy drink that's an
intimidation move there it's like not
only am i going to bow up and fight you
i'm going to take my shirt off first
because all of the blood spatter from me
just whooping you
is not gonna get on my shirt jack
yeah i mean
i'm glad it was diffused
but yeah that's you never know what
people are gonna do and you never know
how they're gonna respond if they're
peeing in their own hallway
just you know just chalk it up to having
to clean it up later i peed in a trash
can one time when i um sleepwalking
i was barely awake yeah
okay i was also a child
so
i had
some roommates
in my first apartment ever
that i had known from my previous year
of college i met them on campus
and we were good buddies we had hung out
outside of class plenty of times these
seemed like normal well-adjusted people
okay um
they ended up believing that our first
floor apartment
was haunted because they heard footsteps
okay it's a college apartment complex
and there were plenty of people
up walking around but they might have
been ghosts during the middle of the
night sound different right partying or
otherwise
and this escalated to a point where i
i came home
after a weekend away with my now husband
and
they had drawn charcoal pentagrams on
the walls and the doors
um
because they
quote felt a presence
unquote
well so that was
yeah that was my first roommate
experience
and my last
no more roommates after that
see there's
you kind of got to approach this with a
little bit of sensitivity because this
is i mean this could be
a a religious
spiritual
exercise this could be a personal belief
set
and i'm not i'm not want to say that i
i'm not ready to say that ghosts don't
exist and i'm not ready to say what
pentagrams will do to them but
i do understand that if it was me i
would be like uh i don't want i don't
consider pentagrams to be like a part of
my feng shui you know what i'm saying
you could take you could go like the
decorative route
yeah it's like let's go we need to go in
a different
non-pentagram
direction with the motif here how about
let's just not do charcoal on the walls
charcoal is
semi-permanent or is totally washable
if it was sharpie i think it depends on
if we're talking about an eggshell or a
flat paint
well
i got another podcast for that
which i listened to your dad talk my
wife and i were listening to dispatches
from myrtle beach
and he was talking about eggshell and
satin you know and gloss and yeah i was
completely on charles's side about this
about how you want to use an eggshell in
a bathroom and not a gloss and jessie
who's you know she's a designer she has
these opinions and she was like oh i
like to
oh i like to do a i like a gloss in the
in the in the bathroom i was like ah too
shiny shows too many imperfections
egg shell you're not gonna be happy with
it um
yeah so anyway i i i do i do different
she's got beef with my dad
they're gonna have to face off no she
didn't completely disagree with him but
she's just done
in a well-constructed bathroom where the
sheetrock work was was high quality
sometimes that extra sheen gives a a
you know makes you feel a little more
alive well my my dad has gotten good
over the years of
navigating
women in his life who disagree with him
yeah yeah that's his job you know
he's he he learns to be quiet and i'm
not talking about clients i'm just
talking about just relationships that's
what he told me he learned to keep his
mouth shut
so he'd probably just let her win most
things resolve themselves without saying
anything that's what he's telling me uh
yeah this is a tough one because
yeah i mean first of all depending on
your
you know your religious disposition it
seems like a pentagram
might invite
if you're already believing in the
supernatural of some some
not ghosts but demons yeah with the
pentagram you may be inviting something
more sinister into the situation i don't
know enough about it to tell you one way
or another but it seems like that's
maybe
it's like hey it you know
how about just do the cross on the
let's do a cross on the
on on the door right you there has to if
there's a clash of personal beliefs here
then there's you've got to figure out
what it is you got it yeah you got to
figure out like what is the overall
religious disposition of the house we
got to be on the same team here
in order to deal with these spirits in
the way that we we think is going to be
effective
i don't know this is that kind of
reminds me of the uh i don't remember
many of the details but you know kiko
told us about the story of the haunted
yeah but they were they everyone in the
house was kind of
undeniably
on the same page like well i mean they
kind of in denial about it no they they
were they were they all were like yes
something's going on here there was
agreement actually that's what i
remember
yeah
i think you have to join if you want
everyone to be dealing with these
spirits in the same way you have to join
a coven
where you all think the same thing
or a bible study
you know like
you have to pick you got to pick your
side and then when you're talking about
a roommate that's like how do you
like
she was trying to ascertain like is this
person do i vibe with this person oh i
mean the way she put it was like is this
person like
normal you know i she didn't say the
word normal i can't remember what she
said but you know what i'm saying so if
you want to like get at somebody's like
spiritual beliefs
that i mean
you can clash about anything in a
roommate situation but how do you ask
that because that that's not a fair
question when you're trying to find a
roommate or is it
well i think isn't that illegal to me it
probably is but to me the specific
situation is
we believe there are spirits in this
home and we are taking the following
actions which
it's not like hey inside my room i've
got some sage and some other stuff that
i'm doing if it's or even going around
communal areas well even taking sage
around like the perimeter of your home
or like that's not necessarily offensive
but the pentagram is it's a decorative
like you said it's a it's a decorative
decision that says something about
this house
and if that's not something that
everybody agrees with ah we gotta we
have a problem
yeah
and maybe you gotta consult the
the spirits too
so i live on a ground floor apartment
and above me there is a family with two
very very rowdy children
um i work from home uh which is great i
love it um but it is extremely hard when
there are two
uh three to five year olds running back
and forth legitimately all day from
about 5 a.m to 11 to 12 at night what
they are running back and forth all the
time
and it is distracting i've gotten used
to it but when guests come over
they're like how do you sleep how do you
exist in this and it's capitalism baby
um but i
one
i was playing
video games one night on the switch i
was up i was moving
um and they were playing outside the
apartment and again i live on the ground
floor
um and they started banging on the
window going are you dancing um and it
ruined my life so i now hate children
and i never want to live in a ground
floor apartment again are you dancing
are you dancing because that's what we
do from 5 a.m until 11 p.m yeah we give
these kids a better bedtime
that's tough man when you've got
people above you
that i mean when we had our apartment in
college that was the last time i lived
with people above me
and it's boy that that
you really got you had somebody above
you in the apartment that we moved into
uh when we first moved to california you
weren't on the top floor
that's true i was on the that's right
out here i didn't have anybody above me
i don't recall it being a problem
that was it was a thicker it all depends
on the nature of the in la a lot of the
apartment complexes uh have concrete
floors in between yeah i don't know
maybe just because of like earthquakes
and stuff but it really doesn't end up
being a big deal don't say the e word
oh you think i'm gonna incite one yeah
uh but we're gonna have to put up what
what's the what's the pentagram
equivalent for keeping earthquakes away
um
i don't believe there is one
it was christy would have found it you
can shoot some like
foam into the ground or something shock
absorbers
um
yeah this is this is so tough because
i think people are protective of their
kids you know if you're trying to talk
to them about their kids it's like well
listen they're just a bundle of joy
well
it's it's very difficult because in
certain situations
it doesn't necessarily mean that they're
doing anything that is uh abnormally
loud if the if the
ceilings if the floors are really thin
kids being kids man but now it's just
these kids the core problem is just it's
just kids if the kids are maybe they're
training for something
i don't know maybe they're gonna be in
like the junior olympics there's nothing
you can do and like if a kid asks me if
i'm dancing you can't let that ruin your
life you just can't
you can't let anything a kid does
oh man i don't i don't i honestly don't
know what the solution is
yeah we feel your pain maybe maybe we
just need to acknowledge how difficult
this is it's like
i hear
that this is tough for you thank you for
sharing
i'm sorry that you have to put up with
this
i think i have a solution and i'm not
saying this is a this is a foolproof
solution
but i honestly basically means you're
it's not no well foolproof means that
they would be quiet all of a sudden that
would be full proof would be we got to
get rid of these kids
and that's not what i'm advocating
um
if you have not yet had a conversation
with the people above you about the
nature of the noise
you need to have a conversation i'm not
going to dictate what you should say but
simply having a conversation
adds a new factor into the situation
from the parents perspective which then
is translated to the children's
perspective and that is
oh
when you guys run around
the woman who lives below us
hears it and i can imagine that that's
annoying so now i'm thinking about that
but if if if this family is up there
just operating in complete ignorance
it's about the amount of noise they're
making
there's no buffer at all
but if you know there's somebody below
you'd be like oh okay you guys are
running around at 5am hey guys remember
there's people below us
it's not going to change everything but
it's going to take the edge off yeah and
you got to have that conversation i
think if there's some sort of well
you
you you get you take a gift basket up
there
and it's got
a toy for each kid and a big pair of
really padded slippers
for everyone
um can you wear these big feet foot yeah
big feet definitely a very quiet quiet
toys for the kids because you don't want
to shoot yourself in the foot by giving
them something loud
but then you're like it's a gesture of
positivity
it's um
[Music]
what's it called when you give something
nice to somebody i would have known
before i got covered brain this is the
kind of thing i can't remember anymore
when somebody you can't peace offering
you can't hide yes you can't hide behind
that the rest of your life man you're
just getting stupid that never happened
to me before
i'm telling you
okay
peace offering
it's there it just takes longer to get
to
um i'm rebuilding neural networks
and then you just give them you just
have a little conversation it's like but
you have to say you're not asking for
them to be quiet at all times you're
just asking for like i don't know is it
like
what's the you work at home it's really
difficult if you figure out something
that you feel like is a reasonable
yet open-ended request for
um
an awareness
and a little sensitivity yep
that's tough man it is tough
hi my name is tanisha i live in atlanta
um i've been listening to ear biscuits
and watching gmm
since you guys first started i have
followed you guys across the u.s i love
you guys i love everybody you guys are
awesome but responding to the
um bad neighbor
thing
my bad neighbor experience i live in
some apartments and i had a neighbor who
insisted on having
um adult fun times very loudly in their
living room that's fine except
our front doors are french doors and
they didn't have curtains so when i
would walk to my apartment and i had to
pass their apartment to get to my
apartment um i would get a show
every evening even though i didn't want
that show i still got that show so one
day i happened to mention
every evening
they got the show
every freaking evening
well like and not just through a window
but through like two french doors doors
full of glass
man
to them hey i got these really awesome
curtains on my front door and they were
very offended that i
mentioned that to them and told them
um or kind of hinted at we don't want to
see your show
um every night and it was like for two
hours which is amazing but it's an
absolute no so anyway that's my story
they eventually moved out after a month
about a lot of people complained um but
that's my story love you guys okay
before we get into the solution of what
you do about this i just gotta i gotta
figure this situation out
we got a couple
who's essentially they're exhibitionists
right because you know that somebody's
watching you you know that you can be
seen this isn't something that you
accident oh we didn't realize that we
were in the living room
every night this is on two hours
two hours uh now first of all two hours
every night you know what they need to
get a television kind of medication is
this guy on they need to get like a
laptop or something you need to start
streaming things it's like well that's
my theory is that they were
okay
so
i think oh
oh they were streaming i think this may
have been a cam couple
okay
and i think that the living room
provided the best lighting and scenery
which is an important choice when you're
making independent porn but curtains
she mentioned curtains but when you are
making
porn and you're good at it and you know
it and any dude
who can who can go for two hours not
consider it
i'm just saying you're not getting paid
by your neighbors i know but i'm just
saying it's part of the spirit of it if
you're if you're broadcasting it to
thousands of people at once
uh well what what does a couple more
neighbors matter i'm not saying i agree
with it i'm just trying to get i'm
trying to get inside them that's like a
headspace yeah i'm just saying there's
something
these are professional especially sex
havers multiple people
complained to the point where they moved
out it wasn't just her
if you're having sex for two hours every
single night
this is your job
you know what i'm saying i don't think
that it definitely makes me feel better
i don't come to that i think that you
can have a job
right and then have sex for two hours
every night you'd be too bow-legged
i mean you could be a cowboy depends on
which one you are i guess
um
so first of all i do think that's my
assessment of this situation is that
there was a webcam that you couldn't see
uh so really the thing that you could
have gotten them on is the technicality
about operating a business in the
apartment complex
that would have been the proper way to
account for that
man now
i gotta say
uh i've stayed in a couple of apartments
or a couple of hotels
in in manhattan where you get that
situation where you are now looking into
like an apartment complex or a hotel
across the way yeah yeah yeah it gets
dark and some people close the curtains
and some people don't
and there's been a number of times
uh when not out of
intention but just out of happenstance
but oh
there's a couple that looks like they
might be about to make love
um
and i i've never seen anybody make love
i think there was one time i did see
somebody making love through one of
those like sheer curtains where you
could sort of see bodies moving but it
couldn't make out any details are you
getting it confused with the time that
you and i both are like what are they
doing over there and then we figured out
they were playing cornhole inside their
apartment well that was one of them but
not i know that was just one one
instance
which i'm just raising that was why i'm
raising a question right now
and i have a feeling that we probably
have a difference of opinion on this no
i would i would look
you would but i wouldn't talk about it
on this podcast but like is it i don't
want to be judged for that i'm just
asking the question if a couple is
making love and you can see it through a
window and it's obvious that they it's
not like oh we forgot to close the
window
you know well
i i don't know how it would be obvious
but i don't honest i'm just being honest
it's never happened
but maybe i would maybe i would uh look
look a little bit well well there was
one time that jesse and i were staying
in a hotel
and
my wife
uh
my wife
uh
likes to you know draw the curtains you
know i i yeah okay i don't and i and i
talk and we were in new york i think
some place where there was there was
another building across the way and i
was like
let's just leave them open and give
people a show i lit i legitimately said
give them a [ __ ] give them a show you
saw them
no i was like if you start screwing in a
window not in the window but like you
start screwing in a in a in a bedroom
that has a window in in don't do it up
against the window because you don't you
don't want that thing though i'm just
saying
there was a part of me that i was like i
feel like maybe i don't have a way to go
though there's a part of me that's a
little exhibitionist because i thought
to myself
it would be fun to it's fun what it's
fun to watch people have sex there's a
reason that people watch porn it's fun
to watch people having sex
and if you can be a part of that in a
non-professional way but just sort of
like oh we forgot to close the window
just every once in a while i think
that's a beautiful part of humanity
uh but this situation that this woman
was dealing with is you can't do it but
you can't force it on people like to me
it comes down to like this window needs
to stay open because i paid for this
room with a view and i like i like to
look at views while i'm sorting the mail
i do
it's part of it like i don't look i
don't look away from
christy the whole time but i might
glance away and say wow i mean i like
wow i like making love in places where i
can't even never sleep i can see there
it is while it's happening like there's
you know it's like it's understood
that's part of it i understood i've
never
and
so that's my main motivation and it's so
far away from other people that like
they can't they can't tell who you are
you're not imposing
they can look away they can draw their
curtains they can what are their legal
ramifications though but it's so far
away that you're small are there legal
ramifications i mean could you what
about children watching well that's what
i'm asking
is that again i don't want no children
watching is there a law record is there
a law
against
when oh open win you know open window
screwing
it that's a good question like is it
okay like what if you did it right up
against the window what if you had your
butt cheek spread right up against the
window
is that wrong i mean i'm not asking if
it's wrong is it illegal
is there a point in which
it becomes illegal
because if you go to a park
and pull your tallywhacker out you'll
get arrested for indecent exposure but
if you're in the privacy of your own
home and you pull your tallywhacker out
and people can see you across the way is
it a crime to have sex with the windows
open hey i love the fact that we've got
this public sex laws in california okay
so where we're at we're in the
liberalist of states
penal code
647a
makes it a crime
no to engage in or to solicit anyone to
engage in jenna's over here nodding her
head like she you already knew this or
you were just looking it up
engage in lewd or dissolute conduct in
any public place or in any place open to
the public or exposed to public view you
can't well okay i just said i was all
about because it's a crime because you
didn't think it was public sex when it
was in your private place but when the
windows are open
it is wow what about new york though
because that's where i do my public sex
i don't i do it only in manhattan i
don't do it in los angeles
so i'm just gonna and for the record i
have not done it
i've only had discussions if if uh if
the fbi is listening to this
because i know it would immediately be a
federal case
if if i was caught having sex in a in a
window is it a crime to have sex in a
car in new york oh is it you are charged
with a misdemeanor oh you're not going
to go to jail but i can handle it but
you don't want to end up with a criminal
record for life
but
yeah but in the job interview it's like
have you ever been arrested well
i don't know why they're let me tell you
a car sec i had sex in a car are you not
going to hire me because of that
i had sex i put my butt cheeks right up
against a window in manhattan
um law
sex with curtains open nyc
sex in your own home laws
yeah i feel like man you should be able
to do it
because they because it's not like
people are like up against the window
with their eyes taped open you know what
i'm saying they've got the ability i
think we should advocate for this law to
be changed if it is indeed illegal to
have sex with the windows open in
manhattan
i believe that um
i believe we should we should advocate
against this law
i don't think this is the hill i'm gonna
die on no i'm i'm moving to manhattan i
need i'm gonna be there long enough to
become a city council member and this is
my campaign
jenna what'd you find
i think there's a case to argue in
california because there's also the
peeping tom law that it's illegal to
peek in a door or window on a private
property without consent of the owner
peeping tom law it's illegal to peep in
a what
door or window in a door window on
private property
without the consent
is it legal
yeah while you're doing it they are in
trouble yeah yeah if they're on your
product the peeping tom thing is again
the peeping time thing obviously is is a
different thing in my mind
because that's clearly just like an
invasion of someone's privacy i'm
talking about somebody get a good lawyer
and we have them
we can get off i'm just talking get off
i mean if you get off on someone's
watching then it breaks that's breaking
the let's start talking about maybe i'm
foreplay and then you close the curtain
i i need to be prepared for this
conversation the fact that we're having
it unprepared to me makes me a little
uncomfortable yeah but i will say
um someone asked
on avo which is a lawyer directory i
don't know how legit this is so that's
my disclaimer
i walk around my home nude sometimes i
usually keep shades closed but i did not
close them and neighbor saw me naked
i was not having sex or touching myself
nothing sexual just was cooking
breakfast
and that's not a euphemism or anything
i looked out my window and there she was
just feel like i'm in my own home i did
not intend for her to see and one
attorney answered a prosecutor could
charge you with indecent exposure if
someone is able to see you nude while
they are in a public place don't do it
yeah it's there's a there's a bit of
courtesy i mean
maybe i'm just i'm gonna live i'm a
live-free kind of guy you know
don't yeah don't do it in a way that
people can
can see you you know that's not if
you're doing it to exhibit then you're
being in it
then that's
i think that crosses we recently had a
friend tell us
that the idea of
being comfortable with nakedness and i
mean non-sexual nakedness i mean like
roommates who may walk around naked yeah
was a southern thing do you remember
this uh yeah i didn't agree and i but i
didn't want to i didn't want to argue it
because
i think he might have a point
you think it's a southern thing to be
naked
i know of multiple people and this is
going to sound nuts
literally i know of multiple people who
say that growing up their dad
would just be naked in the house all
right and and i don't mean this like oh
going from the shower to get dressed i
mean yeah
dad is in the living room watching
sports that's weird naked that's i'm not
saying i advocate for it but you don't
the only thing i wouldn't be afraid the
only thing i'm advocating for just on
the record is that it should be okay to
have sex in manhattan while you're in a
hotel
with your partner on vacation or
multiple partners i'm not whatever you
want to do
because people have the ability to
close the curtains on the other side
that's the only thing i'm advocating for
i think i want to table this as
potentially a whole episode
um just a minute ago you were
uncomfortable with it now you want to do
a whole episode about it because then i
can be prepared and we can get emails
from people lawyers like oh well we can
get voicemails from people all over the
place it's like are you in the south and
did your
somebody in your family were they like
naked all the time or was it just part
of it
like how i think it's that's where how
do you deal with nakedness
you know i
back in the day i said the moment of
nakedness should be minimized i don't
know where i stand i got to figure this
out but let's hear a few more voicemails
on this subject matter
warning we're getting into the poop zone
good
hi guys i saw your tweet about bad
neighbor horror stories so i wanted to
tell you about my old neighbors we'll
call them jim and joette
jim and joette had 250 pound
newfoundlands that used to do on our
lawn pretty constantly
and we would ask them to stop or pick up
their dogs and they never would
so one day on a particularly cold night
after all of their dogs had frozen in
our yard my dad picked up every single
newfoundland that was in our yard and
put it in a grocery bag on their porch
their dogs never shut in our yard again
wow did he light it i love you and knock
on the door
first of all great common this is
classic this person sounds like they
come from a place where
sh is not a curse word like or is it is
at least their favorite word you know i
just love the way they say
yeah it's very percussive uh this is
this is great do you know about these
dogs new newfoundland dogs um 250 pounds
that's a bunch of [ __ ] yeah that's a
that's a big old [ __ ]
again and again and again
but hey that's i think you have a
conversation yeah there there they
didn't respond you got to take it up a
level it's like hey here look look at
the volume of this here it is do with it
what you want
but the thing that i don't like is
having to put signs in your yard
don't poop here like as cute as they get
all throughout our neighborhood where i
walk my dogs
you know i i will clean up my dog's
dookies
yes if it's in and you won't do it
because of a sign if it's in a prominent
part of the yard you're not doing it
because of a sign you're doing it
because you're a responsible courteous
person but i don't like using the bags
so what i'll do is i'll usually take it
and i'll like i'll find some natural
stuff like leaves
and
what and rocks and i will i'll pick up
the poop
using these natural elements and then
i'll throw all of that into like
a more unlandscaped area
oh okay no no no no man and then i did
it this morning no no you you're part of
the problem and then you're this you're
on the wrong end of this you're the per
you're the guy with the big dogs i don't
leave a sh in someone's you throw it
into a more landscaped area not
landscaped a more a less landscaped area
like a rustic area like a more wooded
unkempt unlandscaped area you don't know
what's going on in the area i mean and
sometimes i'll bury it what do you
what's
what's the problem with the bags i don't
like carrying a bag around on my dog's
walk it's like okay okay well and this
is what i know there's a solution here
if the prop i thought you had some
environmental issue like you were like i
don't like plastic bags and i was gonna
say hey
you can get the compostable like
i have those
second thing and i was carrying them
second thing i just didn't want to use
it
you you can choose to do there's three
things that you can do
option number one is what you don't want
to do which i don't disagree which is
carry a warm poop bag all the way back
to your house okay yeah then you're the
[ __ ] okay
option number two
which i believe is much less
offensive than what you've chosen as
option number three is just put it in
somebody's trash can
there were no trash cans out
oh you can always find somebody no uh-uh
you can always find somebody's trash can
and that might need to be that might
lead yeah but i'm walking into an
uncomfortable conversation i'm walking
around just looking for a trash can yeah
put some dogs in in a rustic area you
can't do that
some people some people their rustic
areas are their favorite parts of the
yard some people's children play hide
and seek and they go in the bushes
that's the best place to hide when
you're doing a good hide and seek game
you got these kids that you want to be
outside getting the fresh air and
they're in their favorite hiding spot
and all of a sudden there's some sh
that's got some bark leaves and rocks
mixed in
because you tried to hide it
yeah that's the situation that you're
creating i hid jade and then when i run
around the corner and here's a jasper
like in the street
yeah that's like something and
all of the everything around me was too
landscaped
i think if the dog's in the middle of
the street you can leave it no that's
that's that's just that's where people
walk that's where people drive i and so
i had to resort to using the bag and
then
i got to a certain point and i said you
know what i'm going to leave this bag
here because i know i'm coming back
and then but i'm not going to forget
this bag you left the bag in the street
i left the bag
on the in it's in a certain spot where i
knew i was going to turn the corner and
come back home contemporary litter yeah
temporarily
so wrong and but i did remember it how
about tying the bag around your dog's
collar so they have to deal with it so
they'll think twice about it next time
and it was because the trash cans
weren't out that day
okay
i don't know i listen i'm putting myself
out there
at least you don't have a newfoundland
okay so i
this roommate is way worse than the
story is but this is the this is like
funny bad as opposed to just like
holy crap bad
um
she had a cat and he was very sweet
but
she was not good at taking care of him
and she
tried to convince us
that it was normal that he would like to
poop in the shower and there was nothing
we could do to stop that other than
leave two inches of water in our bathtub
at all times a poop pool we did that for
a year
it sucked
and it didn't stop him from pooping
outside the litter body and she did
nothing about it
oh that's bad oh so they put the water
in the in in there so he would stop
doing it yeah and then you just start
pooping other places
i think it's cool that the cat takes a
shower though
i don't necessarily know if that's what
was happening
um crapping in the shower
yeah there's there's there's not a
positive spin to this i mean if that
were in our game we're still good
we have no no you can do it yeah
this would actually be a good thing yeah
yeah
uh
my cat poops in the shower but we're
still good because
i take i don't i don't shower
it's not my bathroom yeah right yeah um
wow these guys you got to have
responsibility for your pets and you
have to find a solution i mean i'm not
i don't have to know the solution to
know that it's your responsibility to
find the solution
period this is definitely a roommate
relationship ending yeah if you don't
scenario
if yeah if you're not if you're not
solving the problem
i think there's just something about um
one of the things that a lot of these
things have in common
is
an inability to
put yourself in your roommate's shoes
and just think like
the other person's shoes in general
right what
would it be like if
i was them
in their cat i wouldn't care about it
you know it was pooping everywhere i
mean it is a shower all you got to do is
take the nozzle down and just like blast
it down the drain yeah sure and if there
are people like that who that's the way
they think then you just don't be the
roommate let them live with other people
who have cats
i haven't listened to this one yet but
based on just like the header above it
i think this one gets worse than the
last one
hello there rhett link this is the
subject
my roommate crapped in the middle of the
room
i was using the restroom uh we have a
one restroom apartment kind of complex
and as i was using it i walked back out
and i smelled a smelly smell that smells
smelly
and it smelled like a fresh juice
to put it lightly and i'm like what's
that smell and he just kind of looked at
me and was like oh uh
maggie's restroom
and i'm like you had to use the restroom
like
we're at and he's like oh i just did it
in here
and this is just a one room only room
you know other than the bathroom that i
was in
and i like had a horrified look on my
face i'm like where did you use it
and i all i had to do was look down and
i saw a
towel he
used and
and i just i was in just okay this one
isn't over but i've heard enough
you know i i've heard of that i was on
the edge of my seat i i don't want to
hear a towel involved i
don't want to hear anymore
there's no way out of this
break up now eviction
grounds for eviction well but can we
just go back to the cat i have another
cat one well let's just forget that even
though because this is a situation okay
this is a situation you think this gets
better i'll keep playing you know you
have to keep i'm just keep playing it if
you've got to take if you're in a place
that's got one bathroom
and two people gotta [ __ ] at the same
time
what do you do because i haven't had
this situation personally but i have
good friends who have had this situation
multiple times but you don't go on the
floor right go in something well on
something i have one friend in a in a
grocery bag he was with his father and
they were in a motel situation
they got back
you know when you've been out and you're
like with your dad or with something
you're just with one other person you
get back to the hotel room and you both
got to take a sh yeah the older you get
the more often this happens
and then you got to say well who's got
to take more because that person wins
and sometimes it's like well i got to go
more but you're typically a quick
my wife's faster than i do let's just be
let's just put it out there so she
usually gets to go first if we run into
this situation okay
i'm just a tall man i think my
intestines are long or something
but this guy got into a situation where
he won the battle so he's he's on the
toilet and his dad's like i gotta do
this
and so he went and he leaned over into
the bathtub and [ __ ] to the bathtub like
a cat
just like a cat would do
this to me
is it acceptable trash can because you
got porcelain you know you're you're
you're into a porcelain container that's
got water it's easily washable
yeah now you're related and so it's you
seeing your dad
leaning his ass over uh edge of a
bathtub is different than you're just
roommate that i don't know how close
these people were
but you and if they're southern but
but
you got like you got trash cans you've
got sinks
i feel like i can you gotta quickly go
through the hierarchy of where you go
after you can't get to the toilet and
the first place is not a towel in the
living room
okay
yeah that's disqualifying i think you
just you take their name off the lease
if they do that all right
let's wrap it up with just
let's go back to cats
hey boys
i'm calling with my uh bad roommate
horror story
i lived for a short period of time with
an older lady
and her two cats who were also older
um
one of them unfortunately passed away
from old age she was
well into her 20s wow and
[Music]
my roommate wasn't quite sure what to do
so she
cleared all of my food out of the
refrigerator put her dead cat in a
shoebox and kept it in the refrigerator
until she could figure it out
i didn't live there for long after that
refrigerator or a freezer
because there is a difference she said
fridge man
hey she cleaned the food out first uh uh
did it fit in a drawer would you put it
in the fruit drawer or the
the fresh drawer you got to keep that
thing i think you put it in the meat
drawer you got to put it in the fresh
store can we figure it out put it where
the bacon goes
figure what out
am i going to get it stuffed yeah it's
like i mean you should have put it in
the face i just need some time to figure
this out
oh gosh
this is so disturbing
oh
poor
poor this is just a this is just a sad
sad story
i mean
do you how do you
what's the
i mean it was in a box
but still but not a bag
i know because you i mean i feel like i
could be like i feel like if you really
are gonna if you need to put your cat in
a fridge
first of all put it in the freezer
second of all put in a bag
third of all tie it up lie about what it
is
you know
what'd you put in there oh
my cousin went halibut fishing in in
canada you know
and so yeah i don't know when i'm going
to get to that halibut you just
there's just so many other ways around
this i wonder how she found out did she
like where's my food this box and then
she she's peeking in the box you know
that is a shocking moment oh gosh but
you know if
if the cat's 20 and like it's an you
know it's an elderly roommate it's like
i mean you
the older you get the more leeway you
get with like some refrigerating
yeah i mean
i don't know how it was rectified but oh
my goodness
is that what you want to end on i guess
we're ending on that one dude
that's it
that is
man i'm
i'm i'm glad that the people i live with
i can say anything i need to say to them
they can say anything they need to say
to me
and we're and we're
pretty much
we don't align and agree on everything
but
oh we can we can work through it that is
the common thread that is the common
thread in all these situations we stress
on a regular basis communication is key
you got to keep those communication
lines open
especially if somebody's got an elderly
cat
and a propensity to place it in the
fridge after it dies if you're talking
on a regular basis before that happens
then maybe it won't happen you know just
right yeah just keep talking to your
roommates and if your roommates won't
talk to you
and they're doing weird stuff
you know what just
keep an eye on that lease end date
and figure out a new situation if you
can alright i got a wreck for you you
can end with something to listen to on
your own time uh a while back i tweeted
how did i get here and i put a
screenshot of my spotify where i was
it was just the lyrics were all
icelandic
and i was listening to this icelandic
folk pop
that i didn't know how i got to it but
then
i realized there was some english
and there's this it's an it's the same
artist that i tweeted
called ashgar ozger it's a with some
sort of symbol over it
s-g-e-i-r
and the song that you gotta listen to
i'm obsessed with this song
king and cross
it's just like
the the the way that it transitions
sounds like a 90s christian song just so
you know it's from 2013 uh
his album in the silence so yeah i've
been sleeping on this icelandic
fault guy those icelanders will they'll
do some stuff kingdom cross is an
amazing song it like has this unexpected
like
it goes into a different gear and the
way that it does
is just
it's just very interesting we got a
tempo change it's it's
it's a yeah it's a tempo change but it's
like
i d you know i just love the transition
from the verse to the bridge and of this
thing you have to listen to it to to
know what i'm talking about king and
cross as gear
i'm it's my it's okay it's the song that
i'm obsessed with right now i'll have to
check it out and you will too
uh thank you for all these voice mails
that was fun we're gonna keep asking you
to send us uh messages and stories and
you know what you can always do you
don't have to wait for us to do a
specific prompt if you've got a question
an observation something that you want
to say about ear biscuits or something
you'd like to hear us talk to you know
talk about just leave a message
listen to them 888
earpod
your biscuits too
see you next week hi your biscuits um
i'm staying anonymous here but i want to
preface this by saying i know that this
is not her fault in any way um she
couldn't control this
but my freshman year of college i got
assigned randomly to a dorm
with a girl who had
frequent night terrors and so she would
wake up um
around three in the morning almost every
night
screaming
bloody murder and would get up and run
across the room she would go jiggle the
door handle and scream no no no no no no
and then she would just walk back to bed
and keep sleeping and i had to deal with
that for an entire school year
and i know it's not her fault but
it was a horror for me to witness hello
rhett and link this is david long time
listener first time caller so i have a
quick horror story about my
former roommate i lived with them for
about seven months and during that
entire seven months they never once ever
washed their towel that they used for
showers um i would see them frequently
using it as a hand towel and blowing
their nose and after a shower
so after like seven months of just
months and months of just grime and
mildew and filth
he finally finally finally decided to
just throw it away instead of washing it
hey rhett and link my name is ashley
from oregon and my bad neighbor story is
that years ago i slipped on the sidewalk
outside of my apartment and injured my
foot as i was lying there crying in pain
my neighbor came running out i thought
he was going to help me but instead he
hovered his hands over my foot and
insisted that he was healing me needless
to say it didn't work and i actually had
broken my foot in multiple places
love all that you guys do
bye
hey in case you missed it we launched a
new collection over at psyc.la
everything we release over there all the
products and apparel change right before
your eyes so check it out and we're
giving you a discount code to use on
your first visit shop psyc.la drop in eb
made you look at check out and enjoy 10
off your whole purchase eb made your
luck
to watch more ear biscuits click on the
playlist on the right to watch the
previous episode of your biscuits click
on the playlist to the left and don't
forget to click on the circular icon to
subscribe if you prefer to listen to
this podcast it's available on all your
favorite podcast platforms thanks for
being your mythical best
[Music]